hey guys tea here it's time for the ten
things you might have missed in Twin
Peaks season three our eighth video
there's a lot of cool stuff that I've
been looking at since the episode came
out but I do have to give you a spoiler
warning here if you haven't watched part
eight yet then you're going to want to
stop watching this video alright let's
jump right into it the first thing the
nuclear explosion that we saw was a real
thing the Trinity test was the
culmination of the Manhattan Project and
this is the very first nuclear bomb
detonation that twin peaks' is
referencing the scientist who was the
leader of the Manhattan Project famously
remarked after the test quoting Hindu
scripture saying now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
so this is interesting for several
reasons but primarily what's interesting
for us as viewers is that it puts more
emphasis on mystique or history that
mark Frost wrote which does tie in quite
a few real-life historical events to the
story of Twin Peaks I'm going to be
making a video about that hopefully get
it out tomorrow so I won't go into it
here but keep that in the back of your
mind the second thing you might have
missed was as the woodsman was walking
away after he did his job at the radio
station he disappears into the darkness
and then we hear the sound of a horse
what that means is certainly open for
interpretation but it's interesting that
they added that there and we can only
imagine that it means something the next
one is flying frogs in part eight we saw
that an egg hatched in the New Mexico
desert and what emerged was basically a
frog with wings it's been called a mouth
frog by some people and it looks like it
has bugs wings in a frog's body others
have made difficult references saying
that it's locust wings and the frog's
body which would be playing stuff but
someone on reddit pointed out that in
welcome to Twin Peaks an access guide to
the town which is an older book that was
related to the show there's a there's a
photo and a description of flying frog
it says that the Chinook legends
describe the appearance long ago of an
ancestress of the fraud clan they tell
of a house floating in a lake that has
this woman who is basically covered in
flying frog and since that time the
flying frog has been viewed as a special
crest so that's an interesting little
tidbit related to this horrific kind of
creature we saw and the next one is
somewhat related to that too one of the
things you may have missed here is that
when we see Bob in his orb coming from
the experiment's mouth in the stream of
what some people are thinking is Dharma
Boccia not only is Bob's head in that
orb there are a ton of eggs in it we see
one hatch in New Mexico but if you look
at this closely I mean there's just a
ton of eggs that are also being
Unleashed at the same time some people
have speculated that because Bob is in
his own little orb there that the egg we
saw hatch does not Bob which could
definitely be true but at the same time
I think that we could just as easily
speculate that all of the eggs are Bob
but we really don't know but we do know
that that isn't a one-off that egg we
saw hatch that there are quite a few
other ones as well and the next one is
the theater that we see upstairs in the
White Lodge I mean it's probably the
white lodge where the Giants watching
the screen is the very same theatre that
was used in Mulholland Drive for Club
Silencio according to things I've read
it is the Tower Theatre in Los Angeles
that they use for both projects an
interesting tidbit about Mulholland
Drive is that it was originally dreamed
up as a spin-off series starring Audrey
Horne but then it just became its own
separate entity
isn't technically related to telling
twin peaks' in any other way besides the
fact that they both come from David
Lynch's imagination the next thing you
might have missed is that the woodsman
looks a lot like Abraham Lincoln I may
just be slow because I actually didn't
notice this at all I thought he looked
like a guy with the beard but several
people had pointed that out and I just
finished reading an interview with this
guy before I started making this video
it sounds like a kind of really cool
character in real life as well as in the
show but he has actually played Abraham
Lincoln in several movies so that could
have been what made him the right pick
for this Alexandra
Eckstein Khan wrote in her over a movie
pilot in her things you might have
missed article that she does every week
which is a good read an opinion that
kind of makes a lot of sense to me she
pulling it out that the other guy the
one that's you know outside the car and
we also see him in the scene with evil
coupe after he gets shot this guy looks
a lot like call marks so I'll let you
guys think about that and speculate on
about those two people have they're the
two prominent woodsmen obviously and
they do have a bit of a resemblance to
real people from our own history the
next thing you might have missed was the
man from the jail cell and the first
time we saw one of these woodsman was
not the same as the main woodsman he was
not the Karl Marx guy obviously but he
was in the scene dancing around and we
know this from a Facebook post that he
made and he also confirmed that Robert
burski who played the Abraham Lincoln
look-alike the Maine woodsman was
present in the scene as well he was one
of the people if you go back and look
now you can see that he's one of the
guys who's right there over evil coupe
kind of messing with the Bob orb so
number eight I decided to put this one
in here and that is that evil coupe was
shot in this episode part eight and some
people had pointed out in the comments
of my video that the original agent
Cooper was also shot
in episode 8 of season 1 not sure if
that's significant in any way but it's
certainly interesting the nice thing you
might have missed was this convenience
store now of course I mentioned this in
my other videos because this stood out
to me right away and I imagine it stood
out the most people right away but if
you missed it it was there this is
clearly marked as a convenience store
which is I think pretty important like I
wasn't alive in the 1940s so I don't
know that they were called convenience
stores but it seems like that's a more
modern description and we know that
convenience stores as they relate to
what we know about the log spirit is
quite important so it seems like a
pretty you know they pretty much put
that there prominently in a scene where
it didn't necessarily belong to make
sure that we understood that this could
be related to the convenience store in
Seattle where Philip Jeffery says that
he had attended one of the spirits
meetings the one that Mike refers to
when he says they used to live above the
convenience store things like that
definitely not a detail to be overlooked
and the third thing you might have
missed is a little bit of a stretch
because it wasn't actually revealed in
this episode it was revealed in the
soundtrack that's available in iTunes I
suppose there we have we have been
referring to the giant as the giant
because we've always known him as such
and the credits of the TV show he was
being referred to as seven question
marks well the new piece of music that
was playing in the background while he
was levitating and producing the orb
that had Laura's face in it happens to
be called the fireman which is a seven
letter word and it does seem to be what
the Giants name is if you think about
everything we know about the black and
white lodges it makes total sense that
if the black lodge is responsible for
fire that the giant would be the fire
man especially in the context of what we
saw in this episode so those are the
things that I came up with did you see
these all are you like way far ahead of
everybody else did you catch some other
stuff that I
didn't put in this video there was a lot
of interesting discussion from this
video and I always try to read the
comments I always try to respond when I
can and you guys outdid me a bit this
time because there are just a time so
it's really cool I will be doing a Q&A
at some point this week but as mentioned
I want to get this I've been toying with
this secret history video since the
beginning of the season not only have a
break in the action I really kind of
want to get that out tomorrow if I can
but yeah we'll be talking about part
eight for a long time to come I have a
feeling so get involved in the community
conversation here leave us comment what
you thought what you saw what I missed
so on and whatever please like the video
if you found it enjoyable don't forget
to subscribe thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon